vocalism and gender ideology it's a it's
a brand new issue in in in hungary and
it uh it it came
through the channel through the
transatlantic channel so obviously it
came from
unfortunately from the united states but
the hungarians you know we were occupied
by the russians uh
like 40 years and and through this
period of occupation uh the russians
they did try to teach us to marxist
ideologies and constantly in school in
universities everybody was repeating the
the the nonsense marxist ideas so so in
in in an average hungarian or a
grassroot hungarian voter they are
resistant against this
marxist
they were resistant again actually
against the marxist propaganda and when
the vote came in they immediately
realized that there is a connection
between the origin marks its ideology
and and the vogue or the gender ideology
so one of the things that you've been
doing is encouraging
people to have kids because you wrote a
piece recently i mean you're worried
about sort of population collapse which
everyone you know if you listen to
mainstream media it's basically that the
earth is going to be overrun with humans
we're going to have no resources left
and there's too many of us and if
everyone could have less kids that would
be good and
uh you see it i think it's just yeah i
think it's just the
uh other way around so and especially
you know we hungarians we are we are a
small nation just 10 million people so
probably for big empires the perspective
the historical perspective is a bit
different but for us
we think that we have a very unique
culture we have a unique language
culturally we are an island in europe
we want to preserve it and we need
people and we need children who are
ready to
to be the representatives of this uh
culture in the future if we don't have
these people then everything what is
linked to
to hungarian-ness
will disappear and we don't we don't
want to
let it happen so we need people so it
sounds like you're fighting in many ways
the same
the same sort of wokeness the same sort
of top-down thing that it's a little
hard to tell where it's coming from but
corporations and and globalists and all
this stuff when did it start in hungary
or where did it start like how how
powerful is it like is it is it sort of
like america where now it's in all of
our tv shows it's on the news all the
time our corporations are part of it is
it a similar feeling there
so um the voc
vocism and gender ideology it's a it's a
brand new issue in in in hungary and it
uh it it came
through the channel through the
transatlantic channel so obviously it
came from
unfortunately from the united states but
the hungarians you know we were occupied
by the russians uh uh like 40 years and
and through this period of occupation uh
the russians they did try to teach us to
marxist
ideologies and constantly in school in
universities everybody was repeating the
the the nonsense marxist ideas so so in
in an average hungarian or a grassroot
hungarian voter they are
resistant against this
marxist
they were resistant again actually
against the marxist propaganda and when
the vote came in they immediately
realized that there is a connection
between the origin marks its ideology
and and the vogue or the gender ideology
it's a it's a it's a neo-marxist how was
it coming in that was it through
television that was imported or moving
was there something more coordinated
yeah culture and
and and ngos uh media and ngos they are
playing a very important role first was
whether the soccer players
should go down to their knee right
or or not
and um you know we wait so you had your
own version of that relative to the
hungarian player uh no actually we were
we were through international media
forced to follow the this thing and and
you know we were saying that that look
we understand that some of them are i
know it's controversial issue here in
the united states as well but uh but i
understand that some of the people are
saying that it's about racial
equality which is important but uh but
uh and about the black communities but
we
didn't have any slavery in hungary we
don't have any better community so this
is a cultural reference point which is
which is not ours so it's not a problem
if somebody else is doing that but if we
are forced to do so
and forced to follow then it's uh it's
it's it's it's it's something scary
and then um
a couple months later
the
educational issues came in
and ngos and media people they started
to
launch
campaigns
in schools
um
[Music]
you know
how
how to make it easier for children to to
change their sex and and they question
their identity the whole lgbtq
um uh movement
uh came in and then we realized that
this is serious so we we accepted the uh
legislation quite similar to the florida
one
uh to protect the miners and and ban
sexual
orientation
classes without the consent of the
parent
and we were immediately attacked by by
by the headquarters of the european
union by the barcelona bureaucrats
and then we
made the decision that you know our only
chance is
this is common sense what we are saying
and uh and it will be backed by the
people
so we we launched a referendum
and in this april we had a referendum on
these gender ideological issues four
questions and the hungarians uh said
with an overwhelming
majority 92 percent of the votes and the
turnout was was was the biggest in the
history of referendum of modern uh
hungary so more people participated in
the referendum than in a migration issue
than in a nato enlargement issue or eu
enlargement issue and they voted um with
a huge majority against
these uh gender ideological things and
it's a huge success but
where does your media fit in that i mean
was the media doing what our media does
which is here in florida you know
calling ron desantis a homophobe yeah
i mean it's is do you see it as a very
similar yeah it's it's a very similar
pattern but the the only difference is
not only the domestic media but the
international media
is is on us as well and it makes very
hard to survive but
but we have
no other chance once we are supported by
the people so we don't have to be
popular
in the editorial board of the new york
times we have to be popular
among the hungarian voters we have to
represent
their ideas and second
if the western civilization goes forward
to that direction that's going to be a
suicide mission yeah so
somehow we should turn
turn back or turn away from this
direction and and to do so you have to
stand up and be
outspoken even if it's controversial
you mentioned right before we started we
spoke only for just two or three minutes
before we started but you said something
about how the the other uh european
nations that there's very few people in
the nations willing to stand up for
their own nations
and and that seems to be the fight that
you guys have who else is kind of doing
it right are there is there anyone else
poland seems to maybe have a version of
this that's working
yeah that's true poland um is a strong
country four times bigger than than
hungary it plays a very important
role they have a clear conservative
government they have a very
tough nation state vision that they and
they are doing great economically very
successful
um and there are actually there were
everywhere political forces
were
uh representing the same ideas the only
problem is that the establishment is
doing is doing everything which is what
is necessary to not let them
let them in
um there will be election in um
in um in italy
end of uh this month and
the italian bright side is doing doing
great the coalition of right-wing
parties they are
leading in impose so it
would be it can be a game changer if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell